as we've mentioned in previous videos
hinduism is a very diverse religion with
many different practices and even
different beliefs but there is a core
centered around scripture and the most
important of these texts are the vedas
now the word veda literally means
knowledge in sanskrit and they were
written during the vedic period it was
called the vedic period because this was
the time that we believed the vedas were
written and we have a whole video on the
actual vedic period
now there are four vedas rigveda yarda
samaveda and atarva veda
the first of these is the rigveda when i
say first it's because it's believed
that it was written before the other
vedas as early as 3500
years ago the other three are also
pretty old probably older than 3000
years old
now these four texts are a combination
of rituals of hymns of mantras of songs
and of philosophy for example rigveda
rig you can translate as meaning praise
so it's knowledge of ways to praise
praise the eternal or praise god yajur
veda you could use these prose mantras
knowledge of these prose mantras is ya
veda
sama veda this is knowledge of songs or
hymns a tarva veda you can view these as
knowledge of things that you should do
in your life
now these four texts can be
subclassified into the type of text that
they actually are
so what you see here is the
subclassification of the vedas that's
often referenced that amongst these
texts some of the verses are
mantras hymns prayers those are referred
to as samitas you have the things that
are more ritual ceremonies these are
arenakas and aryanakas are also things
being referred to things that you have
learned or rituals to do in the forest
maybe at the time of the when the vedas
were written these were things that
people would go meditate and do in the
forest
you have the upanishads which means to
sit close to or sit near
and if you look at the upanishads it
really is referring to sitting close or
near a teacher there's a lot of dialogue
between student and teacher and the
upanishads in particular really form the
spiritual core
of hinduism it really focuses around
spiritual philosophy and amongst these
four vedas there are a hundred and eight
upanishads and 108 is considered a very
auspicious number in hinduism now you
also have brahmanas which are commentary
now to be clear there are verses in the
vedas that can be many of these that can
be arnakas and upanishads so these
things are not mutually exclusive
now in the hindu tradition one of the
unifying factors are the vedas and the
subclassifications or
sub-categorizations of the vedas these
are often viewed as divine revelations
even though the vedas themselves some of
the authors refer to themselves as as
authors as people who are introspecting
on these ideas and writing about them it
is believed by many hindus that this is
divine revelation and the term for that
is shruti
and sriti can also be translated as what
is heard you could argue what is heard
directly from the divine
now in comparison to shruti you also
have this notion of smriti
smriti
can be translated as what is remembered
and there's a significant number of
smrithi texts some of them that are also
held very
closely and meet the threshold of divine
scripture for many hindus
now the most famous of the smrithi text
are the famous hindu epics
so this is an image from the ramayan the
ramayana tells a story of rama who is
one of vishnu's incarnations going to
save the princess sita from ravana
the mahabharat is the story
of really a family feud between the
pandavas and the kauravas you see here
the pandava princes the five pandava
princes who are all married to draupadi
it's an interesting story in the
mahabharat how they did end up being
married to one princess
and the most significant part of the
mahabharat for modern day hindus is the
bhagavad-gita it is a subset of the
mahabharata and the mahabharat is quite
long it will take you a while to read it
but the bhagavad-gita is quite short and
the bhagavad-gita takes place
really in the the climax of the
mahabharata when you have the battle of
kurukshetra where the pandavas are
fighting their cousins the koravas and
one of the pandava brothers arjun who's
really considered the greatest warrior
of the brothers
as he takes his chariot into battle his
charioteer ends up being krishna also an
avatar of vishnu and the bhagavad-gita
is really about the conversation between
krishna and arjuna and it's all about
krishna reassuring arjuna not only his
role in the universe but it also becomes
a little bit of a layer of the spiritual
philosophy discussed in the upanishads
in modern day india
the bhagavad-gita is probably the
scripture that is most cited by modern
hindus so if you really want to
understand the spiritual core of
hinduism the best place to look are the
upanishads and you also have the
bhagavad-gita which even though it's
part of the mahabharata which is
considered smriti
it is revered and is often considered to
be divinely revealed by hindus now this
isn't a comprehensive listing of all of
the scripture that is important to
hindus obviously you have the vedas
which are very ancient even these epics
their events might have taken place
three thousand years ago or maybe more
their composition was over two thousand
years ago
they were canonized during the gupta
empire but there's many other texts you
have things that are believed written
during the vedic period the vedanga
which
relate to things like
medicine
and astronomy you have commentaries on
things like the upanishads things like
the brahma sutra you have the puranas
which literally means the old things and
these are a whole collection of old
stories epics etc so hinduism as i
mentioned it is a very broad religion it
is a very diverse religion and you even
see that in the texts i'll now leave you
with a final excerpt from the
bhagavad-gita and what's interesting
about this as i mentioned is the
parallels that it gives to what we see
in the upanishads and some of what we
looked at on the first video on brahman
and atman
the man who sees me in everything and
everything within me will not be lost to
me nor will i ever be lost to him so
this is krishna talking to arjun and
krishna saying me you could say god or
the ultimate reality he who is rooted in
oneness realizes that i am in every
being wherever he goes he remains in me
when he sees all being is equal in
suffering or in joy because they are
like himself
that man has grown perfect in yoga and
the term yoga in modern day often refers
to the type of stretching and exercising
and body postures that you might even
have at your local gym but it's really a
more general term of how do you connect
to that ultimate reality and some of
what you might learn in a yoga class is
one mechanism leveraging the body but
there's other techniques through
meditation and other things other forms
of yoga that are trying to get
the individual to better recognize the
illusion the maya around them and get
connected to the oneness of the ultimate
reality